[Applaudissements]
c'était le ceser triomphant en 1974 le
maire de fort de france se moquent du
président giscard d'estaing de passage
en martinique où nous avons nous avons
l'habitude des combattants je suis au
regret de dire que ce soit il ya eu
quelques cafés forfait
et celui là ça n'a pas été la coop
martinique
mais trois ans plus tard sur fond de
crise sociale
le ppm fait la grimace son champion et
en difficulté mis en ballottage pour la
première fois aux élections municipales
de 1977 par un jeune avocat de droite
léon laurent valère fait campagne en
dénonçant la gestion de la ville et
l'alliance aux législatives entre aimé
césaire et alfred marie jeanne
à l'heure où la martinique est en danger
de mort pour le ppm valley dans le
candidat officiel du gouvernement qui
n'a cessé de privé fort de france des
moyens de se développer
la menace est prise au sérieux renault
de grandmaison fait imprimer des tracts
sur lesquels valère est caricaturé en
king kong
le film évènement de l'époque
caricaturer est accusé de vouloir faire
main basse sur la ville
king kong puis moi maria alicia mais
j'ai rien et inquiéter la tipp que le le
sej supporters ça mais je me dis non
c'est impossible
c'était des images d'un épouvantable les
gens étaient tellement affecté de ça
même des ppn qu' il n'occupe que m'avait
affecté ce qui est tout à fait faux ça
m'a rien faire je me battais et comme
d'habitude le lendemain d'une élection
juteux marché dans les rues de
fort-de-france j'ai toujours fait ça
exprès marché il ya une fois une seule
fois un enfant m'a pris king kong la wii
je les regarde et il a été comme si
tétanisés et les parts jianguo au
deuxième tour valère est finalement
battu trois ans plus tard sans lien de
cause à effet il quitte la martinique
pour devenir magistrat à créteil pour
son fils le futur chanteur victor o et
ses frères c'est un soulagement
à cause de la sphère king kong il se
faisait traiter de singe en martinique
79 vod moi c'est les teams ont fini
comprends tes des quatre-saisons avions
et militaires
entre temps la sphère qui ne compte
d'après une nouvelle dimension
la perfecta s'est emparé de la
controverse il y en a fait une chanson à
succès
[Musique]
il me connaît
mais gêné
oh
le chanteur d'eugène mona y va lui aussi
de son petit couplet en 2006 soit trente
ans après cette élection
aimé césaire expriment en privé ses
regrets pour la faire king kong
il s'en veut d'avoir dérogé à ses
principes et de n'avoir pas condamné
publiquement la caricature de valère ce
n'était pas de bon goût dira-t-il
un de ses proches
c'est vous